et euh vous dites notamment on est le 16
mars et alors le 16 mars on on sent
qu'il y a un certain agacement un
certain énervement quand quand on quand
on lit ce chapitre plus qu'en colère on
va y venir mais vous dites ce soir la
colère m'envahit j'en veux à tous les
médecins scientifiques et experts qui
ont pris la parole partout pour
banaliser depuis des semaines j'en veux
énormément au conseil scientifique qui
n'a pas recommandé le confinement oui
j'en veux parce que le conseil
scientifique se réunit commence son
travail une semaine avant le inement il
publie deux avis un avis du 12 mars un
avis du 14 mars qui pour moi je les lis
à ce moment-là me paraissent absolument
en dehors de la plaque et donc je ne
comprends pas et il m'a fallu beaucoup
de temps pour comprendre comment ils en
sont arrivés à cette conclusion et je le
décrypte dans le livre et j'explique
vraiment que c'est un lié au fait à la
composition du conseil scientifique
parce que il y a dans le conseil
scientifique d'excellents scientifiques
vraiment des épidémiologistes les
meilleurs épidémiologiste français donc
ça n'est pas une question de qualité
intrinsèque des personnes c'est vraiment
une question d'organisation de
composition où on mélange la continuité
de la vie de la nation avec un temps de
doublement de 4 jours des faits
scientifiques qui auraient dû obligé à
confiner pour éviter le débordement ou
en tous les cas le le l'afflu de malades
dans les hôpitaux à un moment donné et
il n'ont pas été débordés puisque tout
le monde a été soigné mais il y a eu ce
voilà un sentiment que rien n'était
maîtrisé alors que si on avait confiné
ne serait-ce que 4 jours avant nous
aurions eu deux fois malade ouais c'est
il y a quand même une responsabilité de
Jean-François d'elfri vous n'êtes pas
tendre avec lui alors je je il y a pas
d'avis personnel dans ce livre en
réalité ce livre est factuel parfois les
faits sont cruels donc c'est vrai qu'on
on voit des prises de parole et on se
rend compte qu'il ne prend pas la mesure
attend je ne dis pas qu'il l'a pas prise
après qu'il ne prend pas la mesure mais
ce qui est plus intéressant c'est que
lui-même le dit dans un interview sur
France interre en novembre 2020 il dit
je n'ai qu'un regret nous aurions dû
confiner plusutôt personne ne relève
cette phrase pas une personne depuis 4
ans ne relève cette phrase quelles ont
été les conclusions de la crise c'est
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de lit de
réanimation ce n'est pas ça le problème
de la France c'est que les personnes en
charge de conseiller le président de la
République et l'exécutif qui ne sont pas
médecins n'ont pas pris la mesure à
temps de la l'épidémie mais comment vous
lui expliquez
ça je écoutez je crois qu'il faut lui
demander à lui pourquoi il a pris autant
de temps pour considérer que ça n'allait
pas être une gripette je je pense
que il vient du monde du sida c'est
peut-être quelque chose de voilà qui qui
va plus lentement et moi je pense que ça
n'est pas en fait lui personnellement je
pense que c'est le fait d'avoir mêlé
dans le conseil scientifique
l'acceptabilité sociétale les mesures et
un avis purement factuel scientifique
sur le temps de doublement et le risque
pour nos hôpitaux pour moi ça n'est
vraiment pas une question de personne
c'est une question de conception d'un
conseil scientifique qui ressemblait
plus à un conseil d'orientation
citoyen